Apoorva Mehta used to be an engineer at
Amazon now he's going head-to-head with
Amazon's grocery business Amazon fresh
with his own fresh approach we don't
have our own warehouses we don't have
our own trucks and we don't use services
like FedEx and UPS do the delivery we do
that all in-house the service
instacart is simple customers order
groceries through the app or website
shoppers get the incoming orders on
their smart phones and hustle the
groceries to you in as little as an hour
today
instacart shopper Laura Bardem is
filling an order at San Francisco's
rainbow grocery co-op the shopping list
organic apples carbonated water and
pretzels online grocery delivery isn't
anything new Webvan was of course one of
the darlings of the first calm bubble
now it's a punch line to keep costs low
instacart relies on independent
contractors like Barnum to pick and
deliver orders directly from existing
grocery stores today's order is heading
to a local startup while the nanos
satisfied to use it at work pretty
regularly we're getting we're getting
delivery ranges from about $4 if you're
flexible to $15 if you need your
groceries in an hour drivers can earn up
to $25 an hour depending on the workload
it's a really flexible job you get to
choose your own hours it's it's more
independent than most jobs
instacart has raised upwards of 11
million dollars from big-name venture
firsts including Sequoia Capital it
currently delivers big cities like San
Francisco New York and LA but the
company has even bigger ambitions we
plan to be in every
you sit in the united states by the end
of this year
you